[Music]
let's go to greg in lexington kentucky
what's up greg
oh this is getting real now
oh man
that's what my wife said at the altar
so what's up
so my wife and i would love to have your
help
on how to navigate
the sex talk with our kids
let's talk about sex baby yeah
that's awesome
love to talk about um
so just give you a little bit
i mean you and your wife want to talk to
about sex i'm just kidding is it with
kids
yeah talk to you i'm not helping you and
your wife talk about sex but okay so
tell me about your kids tell me what's
up
so we have a 10 year old and
seven-year-old
and
we've always been super honest and
upfront with them about all body parts
and the correct things for them um
all those conversations have there's
never been any embarrassment there's we
don't joke about
body parts and so it's just all
normalized to them
and
the one conversation we've had with our
oldest um our daughter
is her
upcoming
cycle that she'll be
experiencing
hold on dude
my wife had that conversation she
oh she's she's gonna have a period
yeah
not her upcoming cycle that she will be
one day starting soon sir
like you're like you're a robot she's
gonna have a period dude
right
correct say that word
she's gonna have a period hey you did it
all right so she's gonna have a period
not a cycle that one day she will soon
be attempting to begin and start all
right so your wife had the conversation
about having a period
yes okay and it went pretty well she was
kind of weirded out by the thought of it
at first but then
um
shortly after that she just ran to her
brother to tell him the exciting news
was extremely crazy yeah
yeah
so what's your question there
so yeah just
just um how to successfully navigate
that conversation with
um just the basic sex talk as far as
that you know they've never even asked
us how did how do babies get in mommy's
belly um
you know and
obviously it's it's going to be somewhat
awkward when they figure out what mommy
and daddy do in the bedroom
here's here's the thing it will only be
as awkward as y'all make it
now there will be moments when like when
i say awkward like when they become
teenagers it's more disgusting than
awkward right like i just can't have
that picture of my head right so i get
that
um but the awkwardness so i'll just i
mean this happened in my house i may
have said this on the show i don't know
if i did
this is like three weeks ago okay this
is live in the deloney household we're
sitting down to dinner just sitting down
minding my own dad business
i don't even think i'd wash my makeup
off from work
and i sat down at my table yeah and that
sounded as bad as you think it does uh i
sat down a table makeup on ready for
dinner wife sits down son's sitting down
my daughter who's six
just pulls her chair out to climb up in
it and eat dinner and she goes mom dad
how does the boy part get inside the
girl part
and i was like
i mean i just want to have dinner i did
i hadn't mapped this talk out today i
didn't i didn't really know this was
coming
and my wife
i mean she was i'm didn't none of it no
one missed a beat i think my son's eyes
probably got a little bit wide just
because he's a he's a good kid trying to
take care of her sister
um
and ultimately i said josephine has sex
is awesome and this is how this works
and my wife did say later i wouldn't
have said that at the dinner table
because that was a long conversation we
ended up right um
but that's just i mean we just explained
it
and so when you ask me like how do we
address the mother and the dead
they see their own anatomy and you just
explain it as clear as can be with no
weirdness at all
you know what i mean right at all
and when they say do you all do that you
say yes it's
why because it's awesome
or how do you think y'all got here
and there will be a season when they
think y'all have done it three times
and or however however many kids you
have that y'all done it three times and
then one day they'll figure out oh gross
they do it a lot yeah you know and
that's part of the best part of being
kids
but it's it's that
this is where you can
start a shame process around sex
or you can start a real openness
and a
reverence for and a
joy around
all in how you all have that
conversation
that's what we want we want
the normal life not the shameful not the
embarrassing i mean it's something like
you said embarrassing enough at the
teenage years but at this point we're
trying to
hold that off yeah so it can be as
dramatic
as all right what do you know about sex
tell me and one of your how old are you
you told me ten and seven is that right
yeah yes all right so
you you go for a i don't know the old
the old they're sitting in the back seat
you're sitting in the front seats you
have to look them in the eye
um
we
it's so normed in my house that we
haven't even had a huge
event
we did have one where like a mechanic's
conversation that i thought i just
crushed and i i i didn't do a good job
of the mechanics i did a good job of
like the interaction but i just didn't
do the interact the
i didn't
i didn't do a good job but
it wasn't because of the awkwardness it
was just because i explained things
poorly
um but we talk about it so much so it's
a normed thing in our house
and it's not just about sex so often we
think about how to have the sex
conversation
really it's about how do we have the
grief conversation and the tears
conversation and the daddy's have
struggling at work conversation and the
mommy's frustrated is choosing to be
frustrated with dad because daddy
doesn't pick up a shoes conversation
we're creating an environment where it
is okay
to feel things and to say that out loud
okay and it's okay too
is that you hear what i'm saying
yeah that's what we were wanting to like
with with both my wife and i we had one
conversation with our parents
yeah exactly and we're wondering how how
to do that on a continuous basis where
just give them what what information
they need today and if they have
questions later that they might not have
today
how do you i don't put the burden of
questions on my kids
i see i give them we have an environment
in our house where they can ask us
anything and god help us all they do
holy smokes
um
but
when it comes to
um
when it comes to hard conversations that
i need to make sure they get information
i do not wait for them to come to me
because they live in a world where they
don't have to google will tell them
yes
their friends will tell them and if
their friends can't tell them the
smartphone will
so it's not my responsibility to put
those kind of questions put the weight
of asking that question on my kids i'm
going to bring that to them
while also creating an environment where
that's okay so at this point it so you
say you talk about it a lot
i'm guessing just by your your
your
the way the way you describe
menstruation that you and i are talk
differently in our houses so give me an
example of how you like are open about
sex in your house
no no no we've been we've been open
about um the body parts but as far as
the actual section okay okay okay they
have not happened yet okay
no no no so they're ten and seven
yes so they know about sex
we've asked and they're like what is
that
like
they
they honestly do not okay
i gotta tell you i we we i got fortunate
because we just
we
had animals
i'll just put it that way right right
yeah so we we were able and we talked
about nate
one time my son when he was just
learning about deer hunting he asked
um
dad do you still go in the rut
i was like yes i do
um not quite like a deer does but yep
and so anyway we we talk about animals
and stuff that way but
i i would approach it just directly
and say
we're talking about sex today this is
going to be a com like ask any question
um and i would get right into it man
don't bat an eye about it don't be same
as hey we're going to talk about
architecture today
we're going to talk about
uh
i don't know
how
we set the tone yeah exactly and you can
do it together
you all can sit at the table so they can
see you all talking about it not being
weird about it
you can go to breakfast together go to
lunch together and talk about it
but the main thing is getting that first
conversation if y'all have never talked
about sex out of the way getting that
having that first conversation
um if your kids can honestly look at you
and say we don't have no idea what
you're talking like what
yeah they're
they're they are that way and they have
no friends that have brought it up with
them
nope do they go to are they homeschooled
they go to school
no they're public school but even like
we have two dogs and
the one dog will
violate some
toys every now and then
and my daughter's just like you know has
no clue she's like
he must really like that
that little stuffed animal he's always
trying to cuddle with it so all you
yeah all you have to say right there
dude that is a that is a gift
it's a gift from the heavens when that
happens all you have to say is that
dog's practicing mating
and you can actually point out the
anatomy on that dog
right right and so
and you can say you know how you have
this part and that and
then
you know
you have this part and this is how sex
works
and i mean it's that simple or it may be
a little bit weird if the dog's just
getting after a stuffed animal that can
be weird for everybody but it can be a
call back right
i can remember when yeah remember
remember when fluffy was
rocking onto the break of dawn with the
with the the the teddy bear you can call
back to that right the key here is
levity the key here is that balance
between seriousness this is this is an
important topic that i want to make sure
we you hear from me
sex is incredible and it's awesome and
it's
it's um
reserved for these situations and it is
um
it's it's designed and your body's
perfect as it is you know what i mean
it's making sure that those messages get
across and those messages will be judged
on
how comfortable or not comfortable you
are it will also be judged by
how tense you are and how awkward it is
unless you call it out hey this is going
to be weird but we got to have this talk
right
and that's my relationship with both my
kids that i if there's something awkward
i'm going to tell them hey this is going
to be weird and they all go oh here we
go dad whatever it might be right
um but i breach it that way and i'm
vulnerable in that way or or honest in
that way and i don't even i don't think
twice about it i want them to know it's
okay to not know exactly how something's
going to go so that at their ages you
wouldn't think it would be
inappropriate to discuss it but both of
them together
uh 10 and seven
yeah are they same gender
no no i'd break them up okay yeah i'd
break that i'd break that conversation
up for their comfort not for yours
um
it might be weird talking about sex and
they will remember having the sex talk
with their sister or their brother
and so i wouldn't have that conversation
together like that if they were both
sisters they're both brothers possibly
um but we're going for their comfort and
they may want to ask questions they may
want to you know what i mean and i don't
want them sexualizing the other their
brother or sister either
right
so um
and i also would not call back to their
brother sister's parts
right
right um this conversation is about them
and anyway yeah i wouldn't do that
together i would have you know if i'm in
your case i'd have my wife go talk with
my daughter and i would go talk to my
son on this initial conversation and
then in the future
um i've talked to my daughter about sex
my wife talked to my son about it it's
just a part of the rhythm of our house
as are any questions and i think that's
the thing i want to get to after you
have this initial
i'm a safe space here's what sex is and
once you have that initial conversation
then it's about making sure we create a
context where we can
ask anything feel anything be heard on
things and then move on from there uh
have you seen the books
um
like by roby harris michael emberly
no i've never seen him
um i do there are some great children's
books on
talking through sex where i see parents
screw that up is they give the book to
their kid and say you read this no no no
no no no yeah if you want to read it
with them fine i i would start all of
this with a conversation though
okay
just a human to human conversation is
how it started
because again we are going for
we are norming this thing
like if if you
oh man if you
um
i'm trying to
you wouldn't read a children's book on
much anything else to explain something
to your kid right yeah right you would
explain it now if they showed interest
in it you might then get a children's
book about it so that's that's what i
would say here think think first this is
about relationship building less about
sex how about that
yeah that's perfect think about build
you're building a relationship with your
kids
and
is a part of relationship building i'm
letting them know i'm a safe person to
talk about sex in fact i'm the person
i'm your go-to
on this stuff yeah and it's not weird
it's not whatever and you and mom do
that yep
it's private but yep
and i wouldn't bat an eye about it you
don't want them to ever think it's
something to
do in secret or quiet right do you hear
me on this greg thank you for being a
dad who wants to have these
conversations
oh yeah we got to have more dads and
moms out there norming sex norming body
parts we just got generations and
generations of kids who
um grew up to be adults and thought
their bodies were something to be
ashamed of and they thought sex was
something to be ashamed of and they
didn't they couldn't say it in public
um
don't be that dad that berates their
daughter or makes jokes at their
daughter's expense but also don't be the
dad that calls it
the cycle that they may one day be
experiencing either right deal
still all right good hey brother i'm
grateful for you um thanks for fighting
the good fight man parents talk to your
kids about sex
god almighty do it
thanks for being good parents greg